now that the democrats are done it's
president trump's turn
all eyes turn to the republican national
convention it's set to kick off on
monday
so what does the president need to do
next week to counter joe biden's
powerful message
former obama campaign official david
plouffe has some thoughts
he's he's basically continuing to dig
his own political grave
and so the question is is he able to
change next week
are those voters going to hear something
new something more hopeful
something more disciplined or are we
gonna hear about hunter biden and the
elections fraudulent
uh and barack obama is a criminal like
his base will love that they'll cheer
and the rest of the american people are
gonna tune him out
and the president's been giving us a
taste of what we can expect next week
biden is just a trojan horse for
socialism
in february biden said if you elect me
your taxes are going to be raised
if you want a vision of your life under
biden presidency
think of the smoldering ruins in
minneapolis but he spent the last half
century in washington
selling out our country and ripping off
our jobs and
if our opponents prevail no one
will be safe in our country and no one
will be spared
martha let me begin with you since you
were you were there last night as jesse
pointed out
you know the democrats in some ways
exceeded expectations in the midst of
this virtual convention format
the bar has been set pretty high so what
do you expect next week from
president trump uh in terms of guests in
terms of themes
for his convention you know i mean this
was a really
warm and fuzzy convention that the
democrats put on i'm not sure that
that's what everybody is looking for
a lot of emotion a lot of all of that i
would expect that you're going to see
a different tone the president has
always said since he ran
in 2016 you know you don't like my tone
and then he goes on to list the things
that he cares about right
so i think that's what you're going to
hear from him i also think that the
attacks that were leveled against him
during the democratic national
convention
were really nothing new that we didn't
hear in the last round
when he ran so all of these things are
kind of baked in the cake i think people
either love president
trump or they don't i don't know that
either one of these experiences really
changes that that much
but keep in mind a few things the polls
are now tied in minnesota
and in pennsylvania those are two
markers that are
things to watch because this is
narrowing this race
also think about some of the moments
that we're going to see we're going to
see alice johnson
she's going to take the stage and she's
going to talk about prison reform she's
going to talk about real things that
happened
over the last four years that changed
her life and that changed the lives of
many others
you're also going to hear from nikki
haley and christine
these are going to be really important
speeches when it comes to speaking to
suburban women across this nation and my
guess is that they're going to make a
very forceful defense of president trump
in terms of the things that matter
in their opinion to women and the things
that they see as accomplishments that
he's made so i would look for it to be
you know a little bit more on the
substantive side which you would expect
because you've got a presidency with a
record
and you've got things to point to rather
than something that's aspirational
which tends to fall into the more sort
of emotion
appeal that we saw during the course of
this week
jesse do you think that in fact the
republicans might
start putting out the word you know
trump is better
when he's just off the cuff he's not so
great at doing scripted
presentations is that going to be a way
to lower the bar for trump
first i'd like to take issue with the
fact that you said that they set
high expectations with the dnc one were
we watching the same convention they
looked like a
high school audiovisual team put that
together
bar is pretty low and i think the
president will exceed those expectations
here are my suggestions for the rnc
ended earlier i need my beauty sleep
california's not voting for the
president anyway i'd say
like 10 o'clock tops you're out rap
also musical acts i'm sure kid rock
would be available
that get people fired up also don't be
afraid to deploy your secret weapon
melania she's a difference maker in the
swing states everybody loves melania
but the president does have momentum
with the virus
the cases the hospitalizations and the
deaths have been trending down for four
straight weeks and the democrats want to
keep you locked down want to shut down
the schools
the president needs to say this is an
american comeback story the democrats
are standing in the way
of the american comeback also
the success that he had in the first
three and a half years
is historic when you talk about a
mideast peace deal decimating isis
300 miles of border wall judges
fatter paychecks trade deals
you can just go down the list and it's a
huge success remind
people where we were and where we're
going to continue to go
don't be afraid to take a few shots at
the fake news media they
have to air it i'd put a nice montage
together and show them
who you're really running against
because you're not just running against
biden
and that makes the trump voter believe
that they're underdogs and they still
are underdogs
and that's a good way to fight joe i
think
needs to be defined and has been defined
effectively after the last month trey
hit on it earlier
this is a lifelong washington politician
that has betrayed the country
all talk no action left this country
open for china
and illegal aliens to prey upon it and
he will be a puppet for the radical left
and has no clue
what's going on but more importantly
ended at 10 o'clock
all right so greg i think i think
i think one of the president's strengths
is that he's a showman
and i think we saw that last state of
the union you know come on down
and here's my guest and all that kind of
thing so what do you
think i mean what kind of show can the
president put on is it all going to be
about
grievance and the dissenting to violence
and the
the minorities will come into your
suburbs is that what we're going to get
no because he hasn't said that i think
you just made all that up but that's
okay juan
he doesn't say minorities are coming
into the neighborhood you dream that and
you put it into this question
thinking that i'm gonna let it slide but
i'm not i'm gonna call you out on that
lie
you ever notice when trump talks
about foreign adversaries like china and
iran
it's the same way that democrats talk
about american citizens
trump is suspicious of external threats
as a reflex to protect the citizens here
the democrats are suspicious of the
people in america
because they need to preserve their
power so he needs to remind america that
the left has no
solutions only destruction they want to
defund the police
during a crime wave they want to keep
travel they wanted to keep travel open
as a pandemic started they have no
compassion for workers who want to get
back to work
the bottom line they want more chaos and
they will deliver that
finally who is the autograph autocrat
running for president
trump who lets states decide when to
phase open up in phases
or joe who keeps who keeps pushing a
mass mandate
he also finally to watts point he needs
to make a distinction between real unity
and false unity the dems are are pitting
race against race trump from the start
was about uniting american citizens
all right so trey uh if you were the
producer
for the upcoming republican national
convention
what would you do well i would
acknowledge the fact that republicans
have lost six out of the last seven
popular votes for president
so if that's your track record you might
want to consider
changing something you can't run the
electoral college gauntlet
every time i would have the speakers
that lead up to president trump tout his
successes
and contrast him with biden there's a
reason we have other people introduce us
there's a reason humility is considered
a virtue i would tell the president let
other people tout your considerable
successes
you need to set the tone for the next
four years
people are fearful people are
apprehensive you have a unique
once in a historical lifetime
opportunity to be the commander-in-chief
and the leader of the free world be
aspirational
tell them what you want to do in the
future but let other people tout your
successes
and let other people bang on joe biden